McCabe or no McCabe CNN has no shortage
of questionable contributors she got
another one he's got a Sunday show or a
weekend show brian Stelter
he had former Duke University
psychological professor Allen Francis on
and he made this bizarre claim the
president Trump might be more
responsible for more deaths in Adolf
Hitler and Joseph Stalin I've known
thousands of patients almost all of them
have been well behaved well mannered
good people
Trump is none of these lumping the
mentally ill with Trump is a terrible
insult to the mentally ill and they have
enough problems in stigma as it is Trump
is as destructive a person in this
century as Hitler Stalin and Mao were in
the last century he may be responsible
for many more million deaths than they
were is that unbelievable Stelter sat
there did nothing to interrupt Francis's
bizarre rant he later said he failed to
do so because of technical difficulties
dan bon Gino has no technical
difficulties he shows up without a tie
every time he's asked and he was an NYPD
officer work for the Secret Service and
he now joins us again
hey Dan sometimes there are technical
difficulties and you miss it but that
was a long rant how do you not qualify
that pushback on that Brian listen man
you've been doing this a long time you
don't really believe that right just to
be clear I would that was not a
technical difficulty you know how I know
it I haven't been doing this as long as
you but it's been eight years I've been
doing media here's how you know go to
what's this show called unreliable
sources not reliable sources
no I think yeah I call it on you they
can call it reliable sources that's one
of the great mysteries of our time how
his show got the title reliable sources
I'm gonna call it unreliable sources
right go to their Twitter feed and
you'll see they promoted the clip they
promoted it like on their Twitter feeds
so if you were having a technical
difficulty and this was such an
embarrassment for your show which it was
this abhorrent statement this guy made
which was really horrible
you wouldn't think you'd go out and
promote it yet and watch bus Delta's
response again this guy's the most
unreliable source on TV look watch what
he does he nods his head he goes hmm
yeah he's like this is total nonsense
besides Brian
and as you know there are producers in
your ear someone could be talking to me
right now they're not right when
something like that happens they can get
in your ear and say hey listen you may
want to cut this short nobody did that
so if he was having technical problems
somebody heard him because he was still
on the air
why was nobody stopping him short the
reason is stealth is lying and one more
thing about Stelter captain unreliable
sources this is the same guy who's been
calling out this network in other places
he'd call he called out Mark Levin for
being a conspiracy theorist for saying
that there was a FISA warrant on Trump
he never apologized for that stealth or
either this guy's the lead conspiracy
theorist out there and I'm getting tired
of this guy right Dan thanks for firing
firing us up we had to cut shorter a
little bit because the president
knighted States decided to land just
before I introduced you please don't
hold him personally responsible and the
president that's fine I understand you
were very good there you're very good
extemporaneously I like that nice thank
you very much I enjoy your sarcasm so
isn't in lightness